alors l'arrêt de la centrale nucléaire
de fessenheim est ce vraiment une bonne
chose pour le climat ou suntil le glas
de notre souveraineté énergétique
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec gérard onesta élus et europe
ecologie les verts président du bureau
de l'assemblée du conseil régional
d'occitanie bonsoir mon gérard onesta à
ses côtés georges kiejman au beach
présidents de républiques souveraines
bonsoir à vous également georges semaine
bonsoir être avec nous alors cette
centrale en était en service depuis 1977
elle a été définitivement débrancher
vous êtes satisfait cette décision
gérard onesta
écoutez c'était le début si on en reste
là ça ne sert quasiment à rien mais
effectivement il fallait commencer par
une centrale autant commencer par là les
anciennes potentiellement dangereuses
mais je vous rappelle que tenir les
engagements de la france
il va falloir un démanteler maintenant
deux ans pendant 15 ans georges
kauffmann au beach vous quelle est votre
réaction après l'arrêt de cette centrale
il fallait le faire il fallait sûrement
travailler sur les anciennes centrales
nucléaires et en construire d'autres de
manière globale ce qui se passe est un
problème et pour la souveraineté et pour
le climat mais je rappellerai que si
nous fermons les centrales nucléaires en
france
nous passerons soit à des énergies dites
renouvelables c'est à dire d énergie
solaire ou éolienne qui consomme
énormément d'énergie carbonée je pense
je crois que les batteries est ce qu'il
ya de pire en terme de pollution son
entrepôt complète et comme le giec lui
même le rappeler
le groupement d'experts
intergouvernementaux qui travaillent sur
l'évolution du climat
l'atom est la solution peut-être
principal pour sortir du drame
international dans lequel nous nous
trouvons
car cette énergie ne sera pas remplacé
que part de l'éolien et du solaire bien
évidemment elle sera remplacée comme en
allemagne par du charbon
d'une part nous perdons notre
souveraineté
un fleuron industriel français depuis
marie curie alors qu'il y a d'énormes
possibilités
par exemple ce gouvernement je pense
d'ailleurs c'était une satisfaction de
élevé une satisfaction de certains
autres écologistes a arrêté les
recherches sur les réacteurs de
quatrième génération
ce sont des rats c'était le projet
astrid c'est à dire les réacteurs qui
fonctionne sur les déchets des centrales
actuelles
l'uranium appauvri le plutonium dont qui
permettait d'avoir des déchets de
longueville en beaucoup moins grand
nombre mais nous avons abandonné alors
que les chinois les russes les
américains eux continuent donc je ne
comprends pas du tout qu'elle joue on
peut avoir à perdre un fleuron encore
industriels à l'abandonner à un vent de
notre souveraineté à ne pas participer
au règlement du problème climatique sur
la planète
gérard onesta il ya plusieurs idées dans
ce que raconte georges kauffmann ovitz
on va parler de la souveraineté paix
après mais c'est vrai que ce qui revient
souvent c'est pourquoi on remplace
effectivement cette énergique produisait
fait cela il me c'est bien beau de
vouloir arrêter nucléaire mais par quoi
on le remplace d'abord je peux pas
laisser dire que le nucléaire ne crée 0
gaz à effet de serre parce que pour
extraire le minerai pour le transforme
le transporter pour créer les centrales
qui sont des mètres cubes des mètres
cubes de béton qui sont des gros
consommateurs de gaz à effet de serre le
bilan le bilan carbone du nucléaire
n'est pas égal à zéro loin s en faut
je suis je veux pas entendre non plus
que le parmi les déchets de plus
dangereux il y aurait les batteries les
batteries s'ils ne sont pas aux
retraités sont dangereuses mais comparé
la dangerosité une durée de vie d'une
batterie au combustible nucléaire ou la
revanche a sonné la planète pour des
milliers d'années
je pense qu'il faut quand même garder le
sens du raisonnable
par contre en place le nucléaire est
bien par beaucoup de choses
d'abord par une énergie quand même pas
trop les élus autant je suis une élue
mais beaucoup d'élus le traditionnel
même pas c'était cette énergie là parce
qu'ils peuvent pas l'inaugurer ce sont
les économies d'énergie l'économie
d'énergie au coût que jamais le cordon
est pourtant qu avoir habité dans un
bâtiment qui consomme deux fois moins
d'énergie rendre des transports qui quoi
qui consomme deux fois moins d'énergie
que d'un seul coup on règle la moitié du
problème et ensuite tout simplement il
faut regarder le bouquet je dis bien le
bouquet complet des énergies
renouvelables et des pays qui ont des
liens mais pas de biomasse de
l'hydraulique pas de géothermique mais
nous lâche france cocorico on a la
chance on a le bouquet complet
finalement la seule énergie qui nous
manque c'est l'énergie politique ça les
écologistes n'ont alors rien à un autre
puisque vous parlez de politique que ça
va emballe pas vraiment cet arrêt de
fessenheim c'est le ministre de
l'économie
écoutez la réaction de bruno le maire ce
matin chez nos confrères de bfm tv le
nucléaire n'émet pas de co2 c'est une
énergique deux avantages elle nous
permet d'être l'un des pays qui émet le
moins de co2 pour sa production
d'électricité
et ça nous garantit notre indépendance
effectivement georges kiejman a vite
c'était un point que vous sauviez tout à
l'heure la question de l'indépendance
très à la mode en ce moment
effectivement la souveraineté vous
abondez on imagine dans le sens de bruno
le maire je suis pas convaincu que
monsieur bruno le maire avait réellement
défendre la souveraineté nationale et en
particulier industrielles dont plus tôt
ils ont prouvé le contraire ce sont
encore une fois des mots je voudrais
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit
monsieur je n'ai pas dit que c'était là
les batteries étaient les plus
dangereuses c'est évidemment absurde
le plus dangereux c'est dans l'absolu
danger immédiat c'est nucléaire j'ai dit
que c'était le plus polluant c'est deux
choses différentes et vous avez parlé
d'extraction de minerais bien évidemment
ça ça coûte de l'énergie et ça consomme
mais vous savez très bien bien moins que
l'extraction de terres rares que nous
nous refusons à faire en france comme
vous pouvez le faire parce que vous
savez parfaite
que c'est extrêmement polluant donc on
peut le faire chez les autres la barre
des pays en asie et pour la corée du
nord
et puis que la corée du nord est un des
grands producteurs de terreur qui passe
par la chine
certes on n'occupe pas c'est pas grave
ça pollue le sapin lui dans sa peau lui
dans ce coin du monde et toutes façons
des batteries ne plaît pas à bien
évidemment en france elles polluent
l'inde le bangladesh la chine ou le
vietnam sûr je sais si c'est vrai je
suis malheureusement c'est comme ça
avoue que ses valises en contradicteur
je suis allé sur place voir le problème
et croyez bien que je les dénonce rd
congo temps deviendra ce que vous la
différence c'est que pointer suis allé
sur place
pourtant c'était en corée du nord mais
moi aussi je n'ai pas encore eu du nord
excusez moi je suis aller ailleurs mais
sur la la la souveraineté industrielle
est en même temps le règlement du
problème de l'émission de co2 parce
qu'encore une fois je pense que nous
sommes d'accord que c'est le problème
principal est bloqué par le geiq dans
tous les graves problèmes
environnementaux que nous affrontons
avec celui de l'effondrement de la
biodiversité
nous avions des solutions en france en
conservant la souveraineté industrielle
un exemple nous aurions pu conserver ou
ne pouvons d'ailleurs toujours récupérer
si nous avions la volonté politique
comme vous le disiez de récupérer alstom
est ainsi que les turbines qui font
tourner nos centrales nucléaires ainsi
que nos sous-marins et notre
porte-avions nucléaire de renationaliser
la sncf de remettre des lignes
suffisantes verticalement et
horizontalement de faire comme fait la
suisse qu'il ne semble pas pu taper tout
à fait intéressant dans ce domaine là
puisque vous avez affaire otages quasi
totale et vous avez énormément de
petites lignes tout à fait accessible
pour les inventaires en termes de prix
pour leurs citoyens
et vous auriez une politique donc global
de réduction du co2 avec ses trains
alimenté par l'énergie nucléaire et si
bien une chose qui pose problème dans un
reportage qui a été fait lorsque vous
avez dit monsieur c'est bien évidemment
que c'est une c'est quelque chose qui
est dangereux qui demande un accord
global avec les citoyens et ce que l'on
ne peut pas faire c'est avoir des
entreprises sous traitantes
on n'a vu qu'une partie des problèmes en
particulier fissures dans les cuves
venait dans une intervention
d'entreprises sous traitantes
mais là c'est une logique néolibérale et
monsieur renaud niger si je peux vous
apporter la contradiction parce que le
temps qui nous reste est très court je
vais commencer par dire qu'il n'y a pas
moins garant de l'indépendance nationale
que l'uranium qui viennent pour
l'essentiel des pays étrangers dont
certains je pense à l'afrique
subsaharienne sont particulièrement
instable et non je pense que si la
france intervient au sahel c'est
peut-être pas simplement pour contrer la
menace islamique mais aussi pour
protéger sa ligne d'approvisionnement de
son carburant nucléaire tout comme les
us interne au moyen-orient pour
sécuriser le marché de leurs prêts
précieux pétrole donc à pas moins garant
de l'indépendance nationale que
l'uranium
ensuite le le coût du nucléaire
le coût du nucléaire le jour en paiera
le kilowatt nucléaire a sombré prix bien
je veux dire que tout le restera
extrêmement compétitif parce que le
nucléaire est la seule énergie où la
recherche est porté par les finances
publiques les assurances il n'y a pas
d'assurances regardez vos contrats
d'assurance et un tout petit est assuré
contre tout sauf contre les risques de
fission des atomes le démantèlement des
approvisionnements les provisionnements
financiers sont absolument ridicules et
la gestion des déchets etc au siècle
passé d'eau sur le plan financier c'est
également une escroquerie que je parle
même pas des milliards qu'on a dépensé
en vain pour le p r le nôtre mais celui
également que nous avons vendu à ses
ports finlandais qui ne savent qu'en
terme ce qui ne marche toujours pas ces
milliards là je peux vous dire ils ont
créé des lignes de chemin de fer d'un
goût dont vous parlez qui fonctionnera
avec l'électricité qui ne sera pas aussi
dangereuse est aussi coûteuse que c'est
le couple défendu clairement la
fermeture de sa live en tout cas est une
étape 1 pour certains on a eu plusieurs
invités cet après midi dont des
militants du réseau sortir du nucléaire
qui ne compte pas en rester là et compte
essayer de faire fermer d'autres
centrales george kaufmann au beach pour
vous ce serait vraiment une catastrophe
pour la france il ne faut pas céder à
cela car j'ai dit pourquoi ça serait une
catastrophe pour plusieurs raisons sur
ce que vous venez venez de dire monsieur
[Musique]
j'ai très très vite
vous n'avez pas répondu sur le fait que
le giec encore une fois
invite à trouver considère que l'atom
est une solution
effectivement les déchets nucléaires
sont un problème c'est pour ça qui est
tout à fait étonnant encore une fois je
le répète et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi les écologistes s'opposent à
cela que nous arrivait nous c'est sur la
recherche sur les générales sur les
générateurs de quatrième génération qui
veut punir acteurs pardon de quatrième
génération qui me permettrait de
fonctionner sur les déchets des
réacteurs actuels du coup bien sûr
et est-ce que vous avez comptabiliser le
coût que représente pour l'allemagne que
représentera pour la france et que
représente pour la planète
l'utilisation de ce qui est toujours
l'énergie la plus utilisée dans le monde
c'est-à-dire le charbon est ce que c'est
quand y faire envoyer vos chiffres la
production de charbon s'écroule en
allemagne elle s'écroule regarder les
courbes elle s'écroule c'est là et il
met à consommateurs moins que nous tout
simplement parce qu'ils l'ont isolé
beaucoup plus que nous toujours la
question des économies d'énergie
regardez vous avez raison vous avez
raison pour ça bien évidemment on est
entièrement d'accord il faut isoler et
consommer moins c'est bien évident merci
merci en tout cas à tous les deux le
débat demanderait encore davantage de
temps mais en tout cas voilà on a
compris en tout cas vos idées
respectives merci gérard onesta merci à
vous également georges pouces malovic